s'il vous plaît
c'est afrique
chantal c'est bouclé ouais il n'est pas
le genre c'est impressionnant j'avais
des renforts et non on va pas les locaux
étaient alors oser fermer ses magasins
les actions chez charlot
je comprends pas la blague ou non se
fouler pour un entrepreneur mousse dans
le cmuh lag faut pas les moyens ah oui
monsieur mais cette sauvage est
impossible à me faire flouer par la
gauche vous savez pas encore pourquoi
vous êtes là monsieur je vous
l'expliquais ça m'intéresse quelqu'un
qui a le cran de faire ça merci les
hautes alpes qu'est ce que c'est que ça
va détruire
bon d'accord c'est pas loin du tout
moment ses parts merci aux auteurs ce
que j'aimerais que monsieur climat un
peu tendu
on n'a pas des gens n'est évident tous
donc j'ai besoin d'abord de m'assurer
certaines choses notamment c'est pas la
peine de noter vaut mieux pas noté n'ya
pas écrire ce que je suis en train de
dire non pas parce que c'est voulu nous
poser un poste est en fait de cinq
postes d'écouté revoir ou si cet
entretien la nomade mais je vous assure
que ça prend encore certificat
d'aptitude au maniement des armes à feu
nous a pas ça
ces rôles j'avais pu simplement je dire
toujours
ouais mon brevet tient pas sur un nuage
même
travers et puis vous êtes rentré dans
cette pièce est ce que vous m'avez menti
non sur votre cv tout est vrai oui
d'accord on va continuer d'enfler ton
avec une méthode que vous avez forcément
vu dans les entretiens jusqu'à présent
mais c'est parce que l'entretien qu'on
ne trouve pas c'est en ce moment c'est
pas un entretien classique
d'accord d'accord faudra donc dire plus
avant pour être que ce soit et pons pas
pourquoi je suis là disons que la nature
du profit pour rechercher si c'était une
certaine discrétion mais sachez que si
vous êtes ici c'est pas pour rien parce
que votre profil est intéressant
ok
la gauche
on fait du coup ça met un peu la
pression en fait stresser rebouche pas
stressé mais je suis un peu impressionné
en fait tomber
ja poisson être embauchés pour 13 plus
votre consommation d'alcool par semaine
les dix d'alcool d'accord donc zéro zéro
alcool
le dernier la régie consommer y remet ça
remonte à peu près j'ai pas consommer
d'alcool juste aujourd'hui je vais
consommer tout à l'heure par ailleurs un
pot avec cette jason que ça vous serez
santé de cette question là où est-ce que
j'ai consommé un verre tout à l'heure à
14 heures ces diamants dans votre
famille sur votre cv à marquer indonésie
voilà denaisis je suis partie seulement
pour autoriser uniquement le tourisme y
est d'accord on va continuer sans ça
vous avez un profil très intéressant
la première fois que j'avais un trotteur
ce genre c'est à dire
cachez votre prêt sur le
président vous avez de la pression
dansante et d'impression le cadre qu'il
fait que est-ce que vous avez déjà vu
cette personne
c'est quelqu'un qui a étudié avec moi
d'accord c'est juste un camarade de
classe de monsieur vous êtes doté de
rien c'est qu'ils travaillent bien
pour vous c'est christopher pour nous
c'est saturé
il s'agit d'un agent secret finlandais
je pars c'est donc du 6 puis sont bons
le monde
est-ce que vous soyez prêt à couper les
ponts avec votre famille pour une
émission
ouais
la confiance c'est quelque chose qui est
important dans le bail pour nous aussi
est ce que vous estimez que vous êtes
patriotes
est ce que vous serez capable de couper
les ponts avec vous
c'est à dire
vous seriez prête à mourir pour la
france
si c'est pour une bonne cause mais la
confiance importante
la discrétion c'est important c'est pour
ça qu'aujourd'hui
izotope tu viens te plaît
je vais pas vous le cacher vous n'êtes
pas là par hasard
bienvenue le service le plus secret à
des services secrets et je veux laisser
lire votre rapport de mission puisque
par le jeu des mille impressions
maintenant vous allez dire ça ou pouvoir
laisser lire à voix haute ce rapport sur
ben justement jousse et lui avoue
le service le plus secret des services
secrets le bureau des légendes avec
mathieu kassovitz bientôt sur canal +
résister aux pieds de cannabis
après évidemment